i believe in you and that is why
today i am announcing that i'm running
for president of the united states
senator ted cruz from texas has thrown
his 10 gallon hat in the ring for
president can't get more american than
texas
wait what's that ted cruz was born in
canadia
one tarnation i wasted all my good
finger bullets
i'm drew coolidge and can someone born
in canada really run for president
let's find out this is hashtag news
ted cruz is a darling of the republican
party who's had an eye on the white
house for quite a while which is clear
from his
moving and inspirational speeches from
the senate floor i do not like green
eggs and ham i do not like them sam-i-am
but there are some serious questions
about whether he meets the
constitutional requirements for the
office
at least 35 years of age check 14-year
residence in the country
check and a natural-born citizen
ted cruz was actually born in canada now
the founding fathers never specified
what a natural-born citizen means and
they only included it to protect our
government from takeover by foreign
aliens
all right ted cruz isn't an evil space
alien trying to scare us with the
destruction of our world
at least i hope not the whole world's on
fire
the world is on fire yes but his
situation is unusual he's the son of
cuban immigrant raphael cruz and he was
born in calgary alberta a frozen
canadian hellscape that he abandoned
four years later for a much warmer
much oilier houston texas now cruz's
mother is an american citizen which
technically
makes him a citizen too according to
many legal experts
that might be enough to consider him
natural born but in america we don't
care about egghead lawyers or facts
no matter what the law says presidential
birthplaces are always up for debate in
the 2008 election
both major candidates were accused of
not being natural-born citizens
john mccain was born on a u.s submarine
base in panama and barack obama was born
in kenya
no yeah you're right that's what
misguided birthers like donald trump
said
why doesn't he show his birth
certificate
ironically the people who most fervently
questioned obama's birthplace
are now supporters of ted cruz and don't
have any issues with his birthplace
america where our standards like our
chins
are double whether or not these
questions are legit they clearly bother
ted cruz when the dallas morning news
pointed out his dual citizenship in 2013
cruz immediately filed to renounce his
canadian citizenship
in texas you can be a lot of things a
republican a cuban an
avocado hater but a canadian but
according to real legal experts
our canadian is a natural-born citizen
who legally
can run for president and considering
ted cruz's career highlights include
campaigning for george w
bush helping impeach bill clinton and
quoting duck dynasty
i want to point out just a few words of
wisdom from
duck dynasty redneck rule number one
most things can be fixed with duct tape
it's safe to say cruz is a pretty
hardcore america-loving conservative who
isn't planning any secret canadian coup
d'etat
wait a minute did you see that hold on
let me put on my quebec decoder specs
oh my god i have to call barack obama
it's too late this is just a whiteboard
eraser
so make sure to like this video and
comment if ted cruz's canadian
background will affect your vote next
year
and hey please subscribe it really means
a lot to us i enjoy making these shows
for you guys
i personally make them all by myself
there's no crew behind this camera
if you like what this is all about and
if you like being in the know
go ahead and hit subscribe we'll keep
bringing it to you that's it for hashtag
news i'm drew coolidge and according to
my birth certificate i was born in 1990
and died in 2007.
and night shyamalan